well let's get going then and welcome
everybody to the data science hangout
and a special welcome to anyone who's
joining for the first time today
so if this is your first time joining um
just to kind of let you know how
things work here um it's an all
audience-led
informal session
where we want to focus all the data
science leadership questions that are
most important to you all
and so each week i'm joined by a
different featured leader you get to
pick the brain up
and so there's three ways that you can
ask questions you could jump in live
you could put questions in the chat
and we also have a slido which i'll
share the link to shortly
but just a reminder that the
conversation is recorded and shared up
to youtube for anybody who misses it
or if you want to go back and check out
the recording
but we really do want to make this
a open and welcome space where everybody
can participate and we really want to
hear from everyone
and i'll say we especially want to hear
from people from underrepresented groups
in data science as well
and i'm so excited to be joined by my
co-host for today
chase carpenter is the director of
strategy and analytics at the chicago
cubs
and chase i'd love to kick it off by
maybe having you introduce yourself and
a little bit about the work that you do
yeah hey rachel hey everybody uh first
off uh sincere thanks for uh
uh scheduling this and giving the
opportunity to to chat today so as
rachel said i'm my name is chase
carpenter i'm the director of strategy
and analytics uh for the chicago cubs
i've been with the organization for just
over five years
uh everything i work on is on the
business side
and in a lot of ways i support most of
our
major functional areas so it's ticketing
marketing corporate partnerships
uh food and beverage retail hospitality
uh as well as our event operations group
we think of our i stood on our strategy
team and so we think of ourselves as a
in a lot of ways an internal resource or
sort of internal consulting group for
the rest of the business
awesome thanks chase well thanks for
joining us
and while we're waiting for questions to
come in from everyone i'd like to kick
it off with asking you maybe
what's something that you're
most excited about
with regards to data science
yeah so i
it's a really good question i spent some
time thinking about it i knew that i'd
be sort of front and center um
you know i so i spend a lot of my time
trying to think about how to drive value
out of data science the more broadly
speaking sort of data as an asset
um
and so i think if you even if you just
look at the
my title director of strategy and
analytics um
i spent a lot of time trying to find
areas of opportunity where we can drive
business value out of the data that we
have or that we can reasonably go
collect
um you know i think there's a there's a
wide range of problems out there some
problems are interesting some problems
right business value and so where i try
and
focus my time is sort of the marriage
of the two um and i think more broadly
for data science as a as a profession
um we made some awesome progress
um
better integrating data and analytics
into the business operation certainly
within sports but you know sort of
across the um sort of all industry
verticals and so that's
um
part of that is due to tools and process
and and as well as at the academic level
uh some some significant progress in
getting the right types of course
material into the hands of students as
they come up through both undergrad and
graduate school and
um it's sort of been an awesome
evolution that we we're sort of actually
seeing this marriage of putting data
into practice so you can drive business
value for sort of whatever organization
you're a part of
awesome and so for some of us who maybe
are thinking about moneyball as our like
first example of how you use r in sports
could you give us a few examples of of
how your team's
using data science on like the business
side of the house
yeah so it's um when i joined the
organization my first title was
assistant director of advanced analytics
and pretty much everyone thinks that is
moneyball right so it's like player
analytics it's r d
um it's the the book or the the movie if
you've seen that um
for better or worse i i don't really
have any direct interaction with our
baseball operations team we've got a
fantastic r d group um downstairs that
they do some pretty awesome work
on the business side um
a baseball team that
met both the majority
uh of our revenue and sort of our key
business really relates to ticketing uh
right we host 81 games a year and so
there's a ton of effort and emphasis
and thinking about how do we match the
right product with customers how do we
drive demand for for our business and so
a lot of the problems that i work on are
related to
um
ticket pricing inventory management uh
and then sort of the extension of that
is is putting forward
um a great guest experience of you know
on a sold out game we'll have
38 40 000 guests in our venue and so
there's a big operation to uh you know
put forward the best guest experience
that we can and so there's a lot of work
behind the scenes to really understand
what do our customers want how can we um
deliver products and deliver a guest
experience that that meets their needs
and so that's where
i spent a lot of my time trying to
improve or sort of evolve
what those products are and what the
game day presentation looks like
that's cool can can i ask you like
what's an example of
a change to the guest experience that
would come out of data science
yeah so i think uh a lot so the example
i'll give uh really was a byproduct of
kovid which was has been incredibly
disruptive personally professionally
sort of across the board
um we were not able in 2020 to host any
guests at wrigley field we ended up
being able to play a shortened season
but we took that down time as an
organization to ask some tough questions
on what do we want the business to look
like in three to five years um because
we kind of had this extra window of time
in which we could plan and prepare
and so from a game day presentation
uh an experience standpoint what that
turned into
we completely overhauled the access
control process so
um
historically we'd have these long lines
and you'd have to go through this metal
detector and it was just you'd have
someone like poking in your bag it was
not a
not a very welcoming experience uh and
so through some uh new technology and
changes that we
um deployed in our in our
security footprint um we're able to
completely overhaul
that entire process
and once you get into venue um we put
forward um we moved cash from our venue
and put a big emphasis on contactless
ordering for food and beverage
um data science specifically played into
that in several
components because it's thinking about
balancing the guest experience
um there's certainly some financial
components and some trade-offs that we
had to evaluate in terms of staffing and
what we could actually deliver to
to our guests
but it was sort of data it was a very
data
forward
sort of process and understanding the
various stakeholders and what's
important to each group and so how do we
find the right balance
definitely and chris i didn't see your
question in the chat when i brought up
moneyball before
so you want to introduce yourself and
ask that question
oh sure why not um
so chase i'm a i'm a data scientist here
at air force official operations command
and the question that i had posted on
there is just just how much influence
did movie moneyball have on your
job yeah you know it's it's uh
the short answer is a lot um
sorry are you gonna say something else
chris
uh no i'm good
okay um the short answer is is a lot um
i was fortunate enough to play baseball
through high school in college and had
big aspirations to one try and play
minor league major league baseball and
then to be a coach or a scout or
something a variety of reasons that
didn't um didn't work out so i went into
the into the professional workforce
um you know fast forward eight or nine
years and i had the opportunity to join
the cubs organization on the business
side and it was sort of the perfect
marriage of what i had spent being
incredibly passionate about for the
first 22 years of my life
um and then you know married that was
where i had spent you know eight or nine
years on the professional side
um you know i i am a huge in my sort of
heart of heart to huge baseball nerds i
still follow fan graphs and sort of the
money ball type
um stuff in my personal time um doesn't
play as director role and what i get to
think about
and then wearing my official cups at
wonderful thank you
thanks chase i see there's a few
anonymous questions coming in as well so
i just want to head over to some of
those from slido
and the first one was how much do the
players know about analytics and how it
affects them
you know um
so i'd say first of all some of this is
a little bit of speculation and more
sort of what i've heard from from my
colleagues um but i think it really it
runs
um the gamut of some players don't
necessarily have much appetite or
interest and really understanding the
the money ball type
um
metrics that that that we can produce um
on the other end of the spectrum you get
um folks who they they sort of live and
live and breathe it um and you've seen a
huge emphasis from all the major front
offices and trying to find ways to
interject more analytics into their
decision making into their player
development
uh and ultimately trying to position
each
east player for success i think how that
actually manifests on an individual
player level varies quite a bit
thank you
jeff i see you just put a question in
the chat as well
would you want to ask that one live
i can read it
yeah um
sorry i'm on uh baby duty right now
um
hey chase
a long time
a long time you'll see jeff
yeah good to see you too
i'm curious what the um what the tech
stack looks like
at um
at the cubs and is it different between
i don't know the terminology you're
using but like retail and professional
like are the the folks that are doing
the actual money ball stuff are they
using a different tech stack and
um
yeah how is that different from what we
were doing
seven eight years ago
yeah uh it's it's a it's a good question
and awesome to see a friendly face um
yeah for contact chef and i worked
together for five or six years
and then we both uh gone gone on um our
separate ways um so briefly so our tech
stack on on the on the business side i
think relatively standard you know we
have a fairly robust data warehouse
infrastructure
um currently we're sitting on an oracle
tech stack and we have our it team sort
of formally owns
it ingestion all the utl uh work they
also own our our business intelligence
uh layer
uh so a lot of ways i sit on top of that
um in my day-to-day i i have
our or more specifically our studio open
pretty much every single day
um
you know run most of my uh sort of
analytical work through through our
um on the baseball operations side to be
honest we're almost two completely
separate companies uh i know they have a
very heavy um r in python base they also
do a lot of internal
custom app development work
um and so there's more of a
app development focus in that group as
well that they're they're finding ways
to marry the analytics coming out of art
or python and then embedding those into
applications that they can push out to
coaches and players
thanks jeff for your question and i i
did just want to say if anybody writes a
question and you don't want me to have
you like read it out loud or if you're
in like a loud cafe or something you
could put like a little star at the end
and then i'll know to just read it too
but ronald i saw that you had you had
also asked a question in the chat
earlier um
would can i give you the mic and have
you had some context there too
yeah sure i always like to hear myself
talk
um i am not a data analyst i just sort
of play one at work
um
my question has to do
with how
how are your projects
or areas of analysis determined
and i ask that because i find myself at
least in this business
working a little bit with ad hoc where i
have to keep an eye on a lot of what is
going on in various departments and area
whether that's fiscal or
operations or
you know patient throughput or whatnot
and i do get a certain amount of
guidance from oh we have this problem
solve it
but yet it's people who really have no
idea how to go about that so actually
doing
um
a very
in-depth scope of work analysis
becomes critical
and i'm i'm wondering what sort of a
situation you've encountered there
yeah and this is a really generic
question just almost anybody that i ask
is like how does one do this optimally
or is there an optimal way
it's it's a that's a really good
question and it's something i spent a
ton of time thinking through
conceptually when i joined the
organization i was the first dedicated
business analytics hire and so
um i was also joining as a team of one
so uh finite resource in that respect
um i don't know if this is best practice
but the sort of the what i ended up
doing is i
essentially developed three three
criteria and a little checklist that
would allow me to have that that scoping
exercise that that you referenced
um and really what it what that scoping
exercise boiled down to is sort of
what's the size of the prize or what's
the what's the size of the problem um
two do we actually have data that can
help
understand or improve
uh
the problem and then three when does
that when does the work need to be done
what's the timing
and you know by focusing on those three
problems i've gotten pretty adept at
filtering projects that
um are material enough that sort of
warrant a significant investment of time
too that we can actually influence
through thinking about through a
data science or an analytical
perspective and three fits with the
business cadence um and if you you sort
of strike out or don't can't check all
three of those boxes then you can
facilitate the next conversation of
like okay i can't directly help you but
how can we move this forward um and it
i'll
candidly particularly when i initially
joined you have some uncomfortable
conversations because as a as a service
function and a support resource having
to tell your colleagues that i can't
directly help you or here's why this may
not be a good fit um those are tough
conversations to have and it's um
but i think
um
necessary conversations so you can
prioritize your time on driving value
for your business
thanks chase and
libby i see you just asked a question in
the chat as well if you'd want to jump
in and
ask that one
um sure yeah i was wondering about
dynamic like real-time dynamic pricing
models for for tickets that's something
that i've always been really interested
in as a person who does like
optimization and stuff like that
but i don't know how widespread that
actually is and i was wondering how the
pandemic might have shifted some of
those models for sports teams
so
dynamic pricing's it's a it's a it's a
big topic in a huge area of
of focus i
as an organization i believe we began
adopting dynamic pricing
in 2011 or 2012 so we've got roughly a
decade sort of under um our belt i will
say i would draw a big distinction in
how we think about dynamic pricing
versus someone like a leading e-commerce
store someone like amazon where they've
got millions of skus and they have some
humans behind the scenes but they've
deployed um machine learning models to
sort of algorithmically price and and
manipulate um prices in a somewhat
automated fashion we're not that
hands-off um so behind the scenes
there's a collaboration between myself
and our ticketing colleagues and we're
essentially in real time always
monitoring and observing
uh
demand as it materializes
we have some analytical models that help
us
make some estimates on on how we may
change price um
but it is a little more sort of manual
and hands-on than uh at least you know
in an academic setting when you think
about like this is the optimal dynamic
pricing
infrastructure where we've got some real
headroom to sort of grow into
into that type of model
i think that's great thank you yeah i
think keeping the human in the loop like
the algorithm loop is really interesting
um and also kind of the
the algorithm aversion that you might
see where you're like oh i don't think
that's the right thing to do
i don't want the computer to make the
decision for me um that's been an
interesting topic and i think that it's
great that you guys use it as a
reference and not as something that's
automatic
that's yeah i think so part of this i
think is is um
the sports industry right our there's
two dynamics that sort of distinguish us
from a lot of other dynamic pricing
applications one we have finite
inventory we've got 41 41 000 seats per
event
and two that inventory expires it
becomes perishable so i can't sell a
ticket to last tuesday's game um
and then the third part of that is we um
in addition we have multiple sales
channels um and so accurately you can
get some some interesting signals in
your data that may or may not actually
correlate to an increase or decrease in
demand so for example a a large group
ticket order if there is a church group
or some you know we may sell a chunk of
500 tickets
um without some proper treatment and
sort of you know nuanced understanding
of how that did actually flows through
our systems
you could make the naive
you know interpretation of you know
demand is through the roof no change
price um and that
may or may not actually have anything to
do with the underlying demand as just
like when a a group sale closed true for
example
i have a similar question to robert who
just put in the chat should we use
incognito mode when purchasing sports
tickets
i've always wondered that for con
um i mean i would say this is more of my
personal bias i mean you should probably
use incognito for most of the things
that you do on the internet
uh and i would say that probably extends
to
purchasing sports tickets um
no i i mean i think both through our
official primary channel you know
clubs.com
tickets we have a
uh decently robust um ad tech stack
behind the scenes that will allow us to
sort of track your behavior to some
extent and then and you know show you uh
relevant uh ads or sort of follow up to
that you know certainly if you look at
the secondary markets stubhub vivid cp
um those organizations have
very robust um ad tech stacks that i'm
i'm somewhat envious of because
that's central to the success of their
business and they've made the necessary
investments
can you tell us like buy tickets x days
before
just kidding
no i mean that's an interesting one
people do um
we have seen a huge shift of people
delaying their purchase closer and
closer to events um and so
that's a
consumer behavior phenomena we're seeing
across all sorts of industries i think
that creates risk for us as a business
going back to my my point related to
expiring inventory so
as sales get pushed uh closer and closer
to the event date that just creates more
uncertainty for for our business and
where
uh we spend a lot of time thinking about
how do we sort of operate in this
environment that we're watching unfold
right
um i see an anonymous question that just
came in that was since sports games
happen so frequently how are models and
analytical projects evaluated
over what time period
um i'd say it's highly context
specific uh in baseball
there's a couple lenses that most of our
decisions sort of naturally fall into
one is a a yearly cadence um
you know to some extent the baseball
schedule was pretty much sentenced set
in stone from april 1st to end of
september and so a lot of the work that
we do
um the true and sort of final
evaluations for success
certainly sort of materializes
throughout the season but the real
evaluation is after the season has
unfolded
more at the operational level
there is success that that can be
evaluated
and changes actually put in practice
sometimes on a game to game basis but
more often than not
a home standby homestead basis
and so it's roughly every other week
so we can make operational changes
um the team goes away for 10 days and
then they come back and so we can make
some changes in between homesteads
thank you
uh mubanga i see you had a i think a
follow-up question maybe to what libby
had asked earlier would you want to jump
in and ask that
or we can get back to that one after i
was i wasn't sure how to summarize the
the question in there but um
i see there's also an anonymous question
for you chase that was sorry sorry
rachel i was on youtube so that was
basically a comment uh based on what um
chase uh explained uh in in reaction to
this question because i was just
thinking to myself
because the pricing is dynamic so it
means that the system is changing
continuously in time so i've seen
applications before where reinforcement
learning has been used in
[Music]
not exactly the same setting but to set
things like that like self-driving cars
for example
so i was just wondering to myself what
kind of algorithm
they use
at the cubs
so
i would say
so specific to dynamic pricing uh we
have tested a wide range of different
algorithms sort of decision frameworks
um you know everything from your sort of
traditional classic you know regression
based
uh models to non-parametric models um
jeff and i in our in our prior life
worked at a consulting shop that
specialized in a variety of
bayesian techniques and so i've
um
sort of messed around and tried to make
um sort of the bayesian frameworks fit
within the type of data that that we
have um
i will say
having spent a fair amount of time sort
of in that area i think
the bigger challenge that we have is is
more at the data synthesis and
aggregation layer um getting
the various
data sets that you would want in real
time or sort of at the right granularity
or frequency that that we ideally want
to make decisions we run into more
bottlenecks at that later
know any individual algorithm will end
up being somewhat performant
um given the data constraints that we
have so i i spend more of my time
focused at how can i go get the
incremental data at a at a more fine
fine and granularity so that we could
sort of more meaningfully engage in and
more of the
sort of true optimization
algorithm optimization
thanks chase um i see jeff asked another
question in the chat that was is there
any animosity between the cubs and
resellers like ticketmaster
um
it's a good question i
so in the in the ticket distribution
space um you've got a couple different
entities you have us as the the cubs and
we sell on our own channels right you go
to the box office you can call the call
phone number cubs.com tickets then you
have the secondary markets
um but you also have um big different
terms are used but um brokers
essentially people who are in the
business of acquiring inventory
uh from us and then and then selling
those tickets in a variety um
through a variety of channels i think
there is um
some healthy tension that can arise
because the sort of the incentives
that each of those parties have may not
always align with one another um
and and so
in general i think our
our incentives are pretty aligned with
the secondary exchanges themselves
we want to
have the sort of the broadest
distribution pipes that we can and sort
of get our tickets in front of people um
sort of wherever they are however they
want want to to purchase
um you know those exchanges they're
obviously interested in helping to sell
cops tickets but they have a huge
portfolio of live event inventory that
they also care about
um so there's just
we haven't i don't think we perfected
the business model or sort of the
relationship between all of the various
parties
um but in general um
we work pretty well together
thank you and apologies my audio just
got a little cut out for a second so let
me know if it sounds weird to anyone um
but i think i missed the question
earlier um
sep that you had asked and
sorry if i've missed any other questions
earlier too but can i pass the mic over
to you for that one
yeah sure
so i think you you would refer to your
someone asked a question about your tech
stack earlier um but i kind of wanted to
understand a little bit of that last
mile of how you deliver
your uh
your results to the business
yeah so i'd say a a couple avenues um
i we we build and maintain a small
number of shiny applications which ends
up being sort of a deliverable
uh a fair number of outputs will be
injected back into our data warehouse
and then render through our bi layer
um but also i'll admit at least for our
business a lot of my counterparts across
the organization still rely pretty
heavily on effectively the microsoft
stacks but it's excel it's powerpoint
it's word um and
it's been a big ambition of mine to
get away from that mindset but it's uh
it's a real reality and part of it is
a lot of the outputs that that we
generate make their way into other
source documents or deliverables that i
don't own or
or sort of have much purview into
certainly collaborative like you know
board materials
if we're putting a board deck
or memo together
you need to provide deliverables that
can easily be dropped and moved
in those documents
thanks
can i dive a bit deeper there because
i'm sure that a bunch of people on the
call have that
struggle as well um
like how are you going about
trying to
change that or
um like working together with the team
um
i'm not sure i have a great answer i
think what i internally i am making a
conscious effort to shift more and more
of our deliverables into
um
more reproducible you know our markdown
or just sort of fully contained
um
scripts and processes and then sort of
go kicking and screaming
tension or something that we're always
evaluating
so with our markdown does the team also
like generate
powerpoint or word from
our markdown too or
i've tried to be honest given and this
is sort of in the weeds on
the specific formats and yeah sort of
the um preferences that we have in in
those templates i haven't been able to
fully close the gap and and get
um sort of 100 continuity there i'm sure
it could be done um it's more of a
timing and resourcing thing
yeah
that's something i hear a lot from like
the excel reports first perspective too
like around certain formatting
um tatiana i see you had a a question
you just asked in the chat as well would
you want to ask that one live
sure um so
you did mention jl uh chase that you
deal with ambiguity and uncertainty a
lot so i'd be curious to hear what are
your most uh go-to techniques for
approaching ambiguity and where do you
basically stop and say hey this is the
threshold where i'm about to accept it
and i'm not going to dig further
and the second question was just about
your journey since you started on as a
one-man department uh how did your role
evolve and what aspect did you enjoy
most
from business analysis to data science
it seems like you're more into data
science right now and i'm curious to
hear what how it started yeah uh both
both good questions i'll try and i'll
take them in in order so
in
thinking about uncertainty um
i think as an
two
organization
embedded in there one is more the
mechanically how do you um
how do you think about and actually
quantify the uncertainty from a an
analytical
perspective and and i'd go back to a lot
of the bayesian frameworks that i was
introduced to in my in my first job
they've just got some nice
um
academically rigorous and just like
conceptually sound banners to actually
to think about confidence intervals or
credible intervals and
um so use those frameworks
um sort of mechanically i think where i
i have spent a lot of time is getting my
colleagues and counterparts in our
organization comfortable with embracing
that uncertainty
um a lot of
the a lot of the areas where i spend my
time we have to our analytical
deliverables or do
several weeks or months in advance of
those events actually happening
uh and sort of you know to sit here in
the first week of november and and with
100 specificity say here's my projection
for the
ticket sales next july
it's really hard to to make that
argument so but i've spent a lot of time
getting our organization to understand
like here's the range of probable
outcomes
here are the things that would make us
believe that we may you know over index
or sort of underperform
and how much
risk or uncertainty are we willing to um
to accept and sort of what's the
downside of if if we misproject or what
basically what's the cost of being wrong
um and that's that's taken the better
part of my five years here to
sort of get folks to fully
embrace um kobe 19 was somewhat
beneficial in that because we had so
much uncertainty facing our business
that that uncertain it was you know
front and center and there was no other
way
at least in my opinion to like
reasonably think about what may happen
in our business than through
um sort of a truly probabilistic manner
um
i'm sorry your second question was more
on uh
clearly
somehow your role basically evolved but
going back to uncertainty for a second
so you basically you first build out
your modal and then you accept
stakeholders so you you consult them on
what level of uncertainty they're
willing to accept or do you set it
beforehand then you have a conversation
like here's my data here is um here's
the um
here's how far we can go and here's the
levels of uncertainty we can dig into is
that something is that the conversation
you have beforehand or after you build
your model
um or defense
i think to some extent it it depends um
i
try and
before materially engaging with with
colleagues i try and and get sort of
push the analytical models as far as we
can so i have an understanding on here's
what here's how much sort of statistical
power how confident we can be in these
results and then
um
also framing up you know we are getting
into the grounds of like i don't have we
don't have specific enough data or
there's just more uncertainty you're
sort of crossing a threshold of we're
asking for precision that this model
can't really support
um so let's take a step back and sort of
understand what those limits are um
does that answer your question
yeah kinda does because there's no like
it's hard to answer a big question right
so
uh yeah uh and the second question was
about just your role how it evolved i
assume i assume that since you were uh
the first person right as far as
understanding in your analytics uh
uh department in your company how much
did you have to spend on
uh the buy-in uh and business analysis
etc or if the stage that the company was
in when you joined them
uh was
i guess kind of cognizant enough
of the processes so you didn't have to
spend a lot of time on educating i guess
and which aspect did you enjoy most as
your global
yeah so when i joined there was a the
organization had recognized the need to
bring on some more resources in
in
the business analytics area so there was
a little bit of initial buy-in that had
already sort of occurred that that led
to
my role being created
um you know having said that in any
organization you're ultimately building
relationships with individuals and and
so
i was pretty conscious in finding some
quick wins and sort of you know early uh
early victories that i could find to
gain that credibility so that we could
grow into
bigger more complex um
and and challenging problems
uh when i joined i'd say most of the
problems that i initially worked on in
the first 12 to 18 months were sort of
pretty pure plate analytics like the
problems are well defined and scoped
there's a clear analytical angle that we
could bring to the table but it was you
know pretty
well boxed um as i have progressed
through my five years here more and more
of
the work that i spend on where i spend
my time now is addressing bigger
strategic issues for the organization
and sort of somewhat major sort of
policy decisions that we are evaluating
and
i certainly own and sort of bring the
the consumer and the data perspective to
the table but they're
um they're very real sort of
non-quantitative other stakeholders and
other considerations that as an
media presence organizat an organization
and so we're very conscious of
um the messages that we put into the
market and sort of our standing um just
from a from a pr standpoint i've not
figured out how to weave that into my
analytical models
um but that it's a very real
consideration um that you know it's more
of a an open discussion and dialogue
with our with my colleagues
thank you
i see robert had also asked earlier um
what does collaboration look like with
various vendors that the cubs that the
cub uses
um and then libby kind of had a plus one
to that that asks are vendors connected
in any way as far as data sharing
like from a connected supply chain
perspective
um so i guess i
i can libby do you mind helping me
understand the second part of that your
question
in a little bit more detail i've gotta
could go in a couple different
directions here
sure um so i was wondering if
the cubs have visibility
into the data of suppliers or vendors
and if that
goes the other direction as well if it's
even present
i guess sorry to keep diving in here are
you thinking sort of specifically in
consumer type data or more
um
just other like operational business
data that we need to create
uh so i would say a little bit of
both whether that's information about
your consumers that are coming from
vendors who might be servicing ticket
sales or if it's
more of a supply type thing where you
guys have you know business suppliers do
they have visibility into
um
your supply chain or do you have
visibility upstream or downstream in
that sort of sense of the word
yeah okay thank you su super helpful um
so i guess a
a couple parts of that the main driver
of customer data
are ticket sales um so we have sort of
complete visibility into the ticket sale
process um
we have
four or five years ago we began
delivering all of our tickets
uh mobily so you can no longer print a
ticket um you don't get a hard stack
ticket you can't do like print home pdf
thing anymore
uh so through that we are gener
generating a lot of data um right so now
we get ticket forward data and so we get
more insight into
um
sort of who is actually attending a game
um
and
the next evolution of that that we
unrolled for 2021 is through our mobile
ordering footprint now we can actually
tie individual uh now we've got pretty
good insight into the ticket data um now
for the people who leverage our mobile
ordering platform now i can actually
start to understand food and beverage
preferences about that individual which
we've never had insight into before
right historically you'd go to the
concession stand you'd buy whatever you
buy we get like the last four of the
craft card but no meaningful way to tie
that active to any individual
um
so that that's been sort of the main
sources of data we also own
our own wi-fi deployment so we we
generate some customer data
you
there
we do have
obviously we spend uh we have a decent
footprint in terms of digital span
across the social media websites and so
we kind of fit into probably they're
like small medium business category
um but we have active you know uh
engagement collaboration with them to uh
sort of
improve our marketing operations
basically
thanks chase
i i know at some of the like r and
sports analytics meetups a lot of people
have um questions around how to like get
that first job in sports
um i'm curious to hear your perspective
there on maybe how you do that or how
you'd advise others to go about that
yeah so i think finding
finding the first job in sports is often
the most challenging one i think once
you've
found a foothold
it's a pretty particularly on the
business side it's pretty open and sort
of collaborative community and so you
see a fair amount of
um not job hopping but you can you can
sort of navigate the
professional team landscape
somewhat i won't say usually but it
happens quite a bit um in terms of
putting together a strategy to land that
first job in sports i'd highlight a
couple things um
one i'd go back to sort of where i
started if your preference and priority
is to work in sort of a baseball or the
player operations
um
side of the house
there's a pretty clear path of
developing some expertise in
um being incredibly smart and
sophisticated and understanding player
performance um on the business side um
at least for me i had really no
understanding of how the business of
baseball worked before i got into the
into the business but there's some good
publicly available resources for not
only baseball but all the major sports
and forbes does a really good job of
just synthesizing here's how the
business side of these operations work
and so i spent some time
um just level setting and really
understanding how the how businesses
operate
um the second focus i have is you need
to get a little scrappy and and tap into
your network and you know find friends
or friends of friends you know
reach out on linkedin or you know if you
google cubs front office or any team
front office you'll find sort of the
full in general finding the full roster
of of employees so look at the job
descriptions look at the titles look at
the individuals reach out um
start to build some connections
um the third one is you know be patient
in general we are
all front offices are smaller than maybe
most most people would think and so jobs
don't have necessarily have a
uh predictable hiring cadence and so be
patient and
you know do some diligence to figure out
um
when jobs do become available and and um
you know the last thing i'd highlight is
if your heart is set on working for a
front office i'm certainly not going to
tell you to not go down that path but
there are some awesome jobs available
and what i'd say the front office
adjacent industries
you know the the major concessionaires
all employ hundreds of thousands of
not hundreds of thousands hundreds of
analytics focused professionals
um there's a great sort of cottage
industry of consultants that that focus
on the sports space so depending on your
preferences and priorities
um you can land and land a job in any
number of uh sort of sport adjacent
um
areas so
the last thing i'll say is looks a
little bit self-serving here but i am
looking to to add a couple folks
to my team we've got one job description
up right now and another will be up uh
shortly so if anyone's interested in and
um focusing on uh improving the business
operations cubs.com
jobs and um
there we've got some opportunities
available on our team
awesome
something that might be helpful to dive
into deeper here and maybe with the
whole group as well is
when we talk about like being able to
find these opportunities and
networking i wonder how
like finding a diverse pool of
candidates also plays into that and what
are some of the things that your
organization does
yeah um
it's a
it's a it's a challenge um you know we
are
we're making a very conscious effort to
try and
uh raise the brand awareness and profile
of our organization to
groups who may not otherwise naturally
find cubs.com
jobs
the tactics on how you execute that are
somewhat specific to the individual
roles
um but it's a
um
it's a big emphasis and priority for us
um as an organization that i think we
had um
it's just an area that we can get better
and evolve and so it's making you know
conscious efforts to increase sort of
the the top of the funnel how do we
raise our brand awareness and footprint
um so that we can attract a
um
more qualified and diverse group of
candidates um it's something that
um
we're spending a lot of time trying to
evolve and get better at
that's great thank you
um i see there was another
anonymous question earlier that asked
about um
what you originally studied was it
analytics or how did you get into this
space
um so my my undergrad work focused on
political science and psychology um so
not terribly heavy on the data analytics
front uh my first job uh i feel like i
got the equivalent of a master's in
applied statistics a lot of on-the-job
training
uh i did i supplemented that with um
some graduate coursework in statistics
and then uh i went back and and did my
mba part-time
uh with a focus on operations analytics
and marketing um but i'd say most of
my like practical
what i use in my day-to-day really came
from my first job
and are there so are there certain
skills that you're
hiring for right now or certain things
that you're looking for for those open
roles
i would say
yes uh so one just so
we're looking to to bring on a pricing
analyst someone to help us get smarter
on sort of all the things that we talked
about previously with respect to pricing
the second role is more database
marketing and sales operations focused
i think um in in terms of skills um
i think
i need someone to be successful and
these roles in particular and i think
this does apply to a lot of analytics
focused roles in sports is you need to
be comfortable with
wearing a couple different hats um you
know i am not a database engineer by
trade
but nonetheless like unlike working at a
big tech company where you you've got
seemingly unlimited resources and people
get can get incredibly hyper focused and
specific on on very interesting and
niche problems we need someone who's a
little bit more of a generalist and
comfortable wearing a couple different
hats
um
and you know so people who have
backgrounds and statistics who are who
have sat in the chair at a another
company sport adjacent
um
is super helpful um you know i think the
other thing that
interesting contrast between my first
role as a consultant and what i what i
in my current chair is
um we i get to sort of wear the
consulting hat um but we're also the
operator and so
um there is a much bigger emphasis and
focus on practical analytics that we can
actually deploy
um whereas at least in my previous role
as a consultant we have to do all this
super interesting and fun uh analytical
work but ultimately you kind of hand
that over to the client and you you go
on to the next project um we have the
burden of actually putting into practice
what we
what we build uh and so having you know
more of the mindset and sort of wanting
to take ownership of the full
analytical process in the end which um
is a little bit different than what um
at least when i went through school
there wasn't a ton of focus on that last
part of like how do you actually move a
business world through the application
of analytics
yeah
um russ i see you just asked a question
i'd love to turn that over to you to uh
to ask live
yeah thanks rachel um chase love love
the content so far um
you know one thing uh
you know that affects a lot of us the
work in financial services are
systematic shifts in in data right
so think about something like uh covid
right um
drastically affected consumer buying
behavior and it really wasn't something
we had seen historically uh you know in
our data lakes and data warehouses right
so
certainly complicated my job and my
team's job a lot because a lot of our
models uh were misfiring pretty pretty
badly right
and i think you know sports analytics
has always been something that's been
very interesting to me like full
disclosure cleveland indian stand or
guardians fan so i still haven't gotten
over 2016 yet
um you know i've been fascinated by like
espn's fpi and some of the stuff they do
in georgia tech related to college
basketball but i'm thinking about
specifically with the cubs right and
sort of like the transitional state
they're in in the organization uh
specifically you know
trading away uh schwarber uh and bias
and uh yeah i forget the gentleman went
to san francisco but i i would have to
imagine that's gonna make a lot of your
historical data a little less
useful for you and your team do you have
any tips or strategies or have you guys
started
you know digging into this and seeing
what you what you can do to sort of like
make your
maybe previous models uh
better fitting for the new the new
reality you guys are gonna be in
yeah um
that's a great question you sort of hit
on the
fundamental crux of
what i think it means to sit on the
business side of a sports organization
um
somewhat in an abstract sense um
all teams sports are cyclical by nature
right and that's due to a variety of
reasons mostly a lot of its team
performance related
our job on the business side is to
smooth out those natural team
performance cycles and
um you know when team performance is
really good our job is to
uh push the business forward and then
when team performance takes a step back
like we just saw at the most recent
trade deadline it's to sort of mitigate
the loss or put a you know don't let the
floor go as low
uh and so our job is to uh is to
mitigate sort of that natural team
performance cycle and
move the business forward somewhat
independent of where we're at in any
given tea performance or competitive
dynamic cycle
um that's the abstract answer and that's
sort of that's my like dining light and
how i think about how i
how i can impact the business
um more mechanically um to your point
um we are in a drastically different
demand environment um and just sort of
uh team performance cycle today than we
were even four months ago
um
what i have done from a practical
standpoint is you know we have pretty
good historical data and if you go back
to 2010 11 12 13 14 the the cubs were
not terribly competitive and so i have
what i what we have done is
put a little bit more emphasis on
um
more further back in time
but data and demand profiles that is a
little bit more representative of where
where we can reasonably expect team
performance to be moving forward
um so you know just think from like a
waiting standpoint or just kind of the
type of data that we emphasize and
training our models um i'll say to some
extent i we do
try to directly incorporate some team
performance dynamic elements into our
models whether that's
lens or playoff probabilities there's
some some somewhat easy
things that we can calculate um that we
can
sort of update over time but it's a it's
a hard problem yep definitely thank you
thank you i i see uh ronald asked a
great question and i think he had to
drop to another meeting so i'm just
going to read it
but earlier when we were talking about
presenting deliverables as you mentioned
markdown or markdown and shiny
the question was to what extent is
leadership able to process this
information or do you guide leadership
through the results
along those lines
you're providing presumably much deeper
information than the powerpoint excel
crowd and how is this different
perceived by leadership
i think my my best answer that would be
it's highly specific based on the
individual characteristics of of those
individuals and we sort of have the full
gamut of
you know my direct boss loves to get
into the weeds he wants to understand
why did you choose
this algorithm versus that what happens
if you you change these assumptions and
so we spend a lot of time you know
looking at in our script and like
here's conceptually what's going on and
like here's the relative impact of these
different assumptions
um
is that
my boss sort of over indexes on that
side of the things on the other side
you've got other organized other
individuals who who don't
not that they don't have the appetite
but they're more focused on the business
outcome and it's been somewhat of an
iterative process to understand what
resonates to what audience and and um
tailoring and catering those
deliverables
um to those individuals
thank you
libby i also think you had a question
earlier around
the biggest false assumptions that
people generally make
do you want to add any context to that
one
um i think that i've just been thinking
a lot about assumptions lately and how
i'm usually wrong when i make
assumptions about how other
organizations or even individuals use
data
and um
the level of complexity that they
actually use them at and the application
areas so sports is something i'm not
familiar with and i would like to
kind of ask what the biggest assumption
is that people make that's just totally
wrong
somewhat tongue-in-cheek but the
question i still feel from friends
family people i need is like am i
hanging out in the clubhouse and like
having dinner with with our players um
and that's like could not take part from
the
the the truth um you know all those guys
um
if they're kind of doing doing their own
thing um but i think sort of more um
directly to
uh to to your point on sort of
assumptions about our core business
operations i think
people have a lot of assumptions about
um
how
where decisions are are made and sort of
who is um
running the show to some extent and
um pretty much all of your major sports
teams are in some capacity owned by
private ownership group and those owners
have different media personalities
themselves and individual and family
brands
um
that depending on the organization they
may or may not have anything to do with
the day-to-day operations um and but
nonetheless when you when you you know
if you follow twitter or sort of major
uh media outlets the characterization of
the decision-making process as it gets
described by by the media is
um often pretty far from
you know what i observe on a on a
day-to-day basis and
um by and large it's one of those things
that we're not really equipped or
wouldn't necessarily be in our best
interest to
try and change those perceptions so we
just kind of scrub your shoulders and
and
it's interesting seeing how stuff that i
am directly involved in
uh behind the scenes ends up getting
portrayed in the media and sometimes
it's spot-on and other times you're just
kind of like yes that's not how this
works
thank you chase as we get to the top of
the hour i know some people might have
to to run so i just want to ask what's
the best way to get in touch with you if
people have follow-up questions or if
they're interested in any of the roles
is it linkedin
yeah i'd say i'm pretty easy to track
down on linkedin so i please encourage
anyone to reach out via linkedin if you
have any questions um specific to the
role certainly but more generally if you
have an interest or just want to learn
more about
uh the sports industry um i obviously
know the most about baseball but have
some decent perspective on other
other leagues as well um but yeah please
please do reach out and um i'm usually
pretty good about uh responding
awesome thank you chase um if it's okay
can i ask you maybe one or two more
questions since we i just want to make
sure i didn't danny
um
i'd love to hear um what advice you have
for
maybe someone who's on the call right
now that's hoping to get into a
leadership position
and how they could move from being that
individual contributor into leadership
i feel like
the biggest jump there it's it's
probably not in the in the hard skills
um category i think in order to move up
i sort of think of
the hard skill you know the proficiency
and excellence in what i think is like
the hard data science type skills that's
somewhat of a of a table stakes criteria
um so you need a
you need to show a sort of minimum level
of competency or excellent excellence um
in that category but where i think you
can start to differentiate yourself
is more in the soft skills it's the
leadership it's the negotiation it's the
team building
um it's sort of all the
um stuff that um
you know
can be described as like the soft fluffy
skills um but when you think about um i
think high performing organizations have
tightly aligned
strategy and data analytics functions
and so i when i think about what does a
aspiring leader need to do it's it's
starting to develop a knack for what is
the strategy of the organization and how
can i influence that
data in a lot of ways is a tool that can
very meaningfully improve organizations
um but it's sort of
i think you can really differentiate
yourself on on sort of
outperforming your your competitors in
some sense and and those soft skills
thank you chase and i am i just want to
say if i've missed anybody's questions
i'm trying to slide
through so in the chat here but please
feel free to just um yourself and jump
in live too
do it a quick check
i don't see anyone that unmuted one last
question chase i'd love to ask you um
i'm trying to help bring more resources
together for
someone who's just trying to start
advocating for data science internally
and maybe they're the first data person
how would you
[Music]
i guess tell someone to go about that
process if they're in a position where
they they actually just have to start at
getting approval to even use some of
these tools
yeah i think um
where my head initially goes and this
sort of goes back to some of my
my mba
classes but i think it's a it's a pretty
simple framework of um what's the roi
that you think you could reasonably
drive um and right so i would think
about it of engaging with
each of sort of the major stakeholders
in an organization and understanding
what are your problems and basically
what
how
you can think about it in terms of
revenue or just like efficiency
um right if if this business unit is
operating at 80 efficiency what's it
mean to the business if we can move that
to 85 or 90
percent think about some way to to
quantify that um
balance that up against whatever the
sort of
what resources you need to bring to the
table um to unlock that five or ten
percent improvement and that you know i
think about that in sort of the broadest
sense of its tech count its technology
its investment data warehousing right
sort of depending on where that
organization is that could go in a lot
of different ways but
um
you know where
um you know
for for my group we think about driving
um essentially a 5x return on the
investments that the organization make
in our group and that's the sort of the
benchmark in the threshold that that i'm
held accountable to um it's worked well
here um
and i think it's a good sort of forcing
function to make sure you're focusing
your time on on the right problems that
can sort of meaningfully drive the
business forward
definitely
thank you so much chase i really
appreciate you joining and and jumping
on here and sharing all your insights
with us
i uh i hope to get everybody together
there in person at some point too and i
know we talked about maybe next year
there's the sloan conference sports
analytics conference in boston maybe
planning a meetup or something around
that as well if other people are going
to be in the area
but thank you so much really appreciate
it
yeah thank you rachel thanks everyone um
great great questions and dialogue today
i really enjoyed it so thank you all
have a great rest of the day everyone
you